4 I'm 47 how old are you 37 oh it's for
10 years yeah I didn't start doing
comedy till I was 32 inil wow and then
how I want to know because what let me
guess okay you're you're starting comedy
in Philadelphia and you glom on to the
best guys that you see no no no no he
needed cigarettes and I had cigarettes
it was like jail it wasn't oh really
yeah oh you had seen his act like I got
to get into this gu I didn't yeah you
saw my act and made fun of me yeah I
still make fun of him I didn't love it
he was real uh so at the show that he
used to run with like our friends he was
he had started a couple years before me
yeah and then I started coming around
and uh there was this show it was like
an open mic it was like a showcase open
mic and it was really good in Philly
because there wasn't that many
opportunities so there was this Thursday
night show at this place called The
Raven Lounge in the first half of it
they would put up to 10 best comics in
the room to keep the audience wow and
then the second half it was like like
you know they would kind of funnel
through and but if you did well the week
before they'd be like all right well you
know you try to get bumped up it was
real we were Maniacs about it we really
tried to run like the best show we
thought we were doing they thought they
were running like The Tonight Show yeah
W not like in arrogance outside of it
but we were fighting and like you got to
do we got to make it the best thing ever
you know what I mean yeah we were we
were nuts about it and you guys both
ended up being in the first half so he
was running it so he was running it I
showed up one week my first I think it
was my first or second time ever on
stage and did pretty well like
considering and he had Saul or something
and you had what I saw spark in the kid
saw saw oh you saw something the next
week the guy his pimples on his
no hey Rudolph get up there and don't
bomb don't embarrass me
kid wow wow so Vander beaks in the
audience and were you but were you
enamored that he or flattered were you
flatter that the guy that runs the show
what no he was a big fat loser you just
heard the years leading up to when I met
him what do you think he was I was
wearing I was wearing a sport coat and
sweatpant no that's not even a joke yeah
yeah so I wasn't supposed to go I done
well the first time like well you know
considering the first time I was there
and then he was like the person who was
supposed to go up and close the second
like they supposed to headline the first
half wasn't in the room so they saw me
they were like all right this kid did
good we don't know him but he did good
last week just kind of go up there and I
guess do the same thing you did last
week I didn't know it was my second time
doing ComEd I didn't know how comedy
worked so I wrote that five minutes and
then the that week I just wrote a brand
new five minutes a and just bomb so bad
and I saw him in the back put his hand
in his head like but he gave me the
speech before he like listen I'm going
to need a good set out of here go up
there knock him dead give him hell kid I
was big on the speech loved the good
speech and I I ate my balls and then I
didn't get back on stage for like a year
after I was so so scared and so
embarrassed wow I ran him out of the
business by wow You'll never work in
this town again people let me get a
smoke I mean early on those bombs you
never forget I'll never I'll never
forget him turning his head away and
being like yeah oh I don't know what I
thought I knew what I was doing was a
packed room yeah um 50 people probably
the crazy thing to me was back then
thinking ever that I was even okay at it
and like looking back on it how bad you
were how bad like I still think I stink
you know yeah of course and but back
then if you knew how bad you truly were
that's what you have to have that
certain amount of delusion in you to
keep going you know oh that one was all
right that was pretty good let me think
yeah I I
I I think I knew how bad I was but I I I
I could see improvements too that's
that's also very big and also like a
bigger Comics oh good bit or great job
like that keeps you moving like for me
it was like um when I the first year my
only sign that I was kind of going in
the right direction was you know Paulie
Shore and carlosena asked me to open for
them yeah that's great and that's sort
of like oh maybe there's something
there's something there and they're like
you're green and you bomb every other
time but there's something there what
yeah yeah and then you would you know
this is pread TV right yeah pre this is
like when I when you got that you were
like oh yeah I'm supposed to be
here right no really yeah did you think
that um being Asian helped you out cuz
paully has an obsession with Asian
people I think that did yeah that did
help right yeah is it known that he has
an obsession with it I don't know I
don't I don't know the man painfully
addicted really yeah and not in a good
way there's just something about he
thinks we're dogs well wasn't he raised
by yeah I know but he pets me like you
know what I mean Oh Come you know it'll
you know I mean he'll C me like a dog oh
good boy good boy you know what I
mean yeah and it's like all right all
right and he thinks I'm Chinese but
that's fine cuz he sings a song yeah
Chinese yeah he like we go to the Korean
spa and he'll go Chinese people are the
most beautiful people in the world
that's sweet but he'll say it out loud
in front of all the other Asians Koreans
and they all look at me and I'm like
he's
Jewish
they do that
you yeah but um it's all right no but
I'll tell so what happened was I started
in '95 and then um all the locals in San
Diego didn't like me at all like all the
older ones because I realized they
didn't want to help me in any way and
they didn't want to they never went we
were the black sheep of the of the city
as well yeah yeah that's